hey youtubers is Charlie welcome to part
2 of my Walking Dead Season 4 countdown
that's right Walking Dead episode 9 is
airing this Sunday so I thought it'd be
fun to talk about our 10 big questions
before it airs also as a point of
interest
Scott capo said that AMC is really
worried about the second half of the
season especially some of the things
that the show runners have done I'll
talk about that after my list careful
for spoilers if you don't want to know
anything about season four cuz I'll be
talking about a few rumors also if
you're new to the channel I'll be doing
weekly Walking Dead videos starting on
Sunday I'll do episode reviews and then
Mondays I'll do Q&A s and then there'll
be a giveaway video that'll also be on
Mondays so biggest questions for the
second half of the season number 10 who
killed that rabbit my best guess based
on her character arc in the first half
of this season is Lizzie she started out
as this really pure little girl and
Carol basically shouted the tears out of
her worst in real life parent ever but
best Walking Dead parent ever just to
give you an idea where Lizzie is right
now she was able to shoot and kill
someone in that mid-season finale
without freaking out number 9 where did
that giant herd of walkers go from
episode 3 there had to have been at
least five to ten thousand Walker
stretched as far as the eye could see on
that road they didn't just disappear
walkers will generally seek out nearby
food but in order to travel in a large
group like that over a long distance
someone had to be influencing them the
governor is gone now so my best guess is
that it's going to be the villain for
the second half of the season we don't
know quite who that's gonna be yet but I
do have a few theories number eight who
was the voice on the other side of
Daryl's radio he was in that same
episode that they saw that giant herd of
walkers but the best theories I've seen
so far is that it is the sanctuary
there's no guarantee that they'll find
it this season but now that they're
looking for shelter again Daryl's group
will probably try and track that signal
down number seven who was on the bus and
who ran into the woods Glenn and Maggie
were on the bus but Maggie got stuck
with Bob Stokey and Sasha trying to find
Beth so I think we can call the bus
group Glenn's group Tyreese also has a
group he took the girls and ran I think
that Rick and Carl gonna be by
themselves for a little bit so they'll
be their own group number six who was
feeding the rats short answer probably
also Lizzie but since she kind of
checked out mentally over the course of
the season she might not have been quite
hardcore enough to do something like
that during episode one I also think it
could have been Carol or a new person
that we haven't seen yet but that's
pretty unlikely so right now based on
that dead rabbit evidence that I listed
earlier
really do think that Lizzie is the best
guess number five what happened to Lily
the last time we saw her she was still
alive and hadn't been bitten she had
just killed her better half so to speak
but I do think she made it into one of
the groups that was fleeing into the
woods
that means she's either in Teresa's
group or in Maggie's group would it be
crazy if they threw us a curve ball and
she ended up with Rick and Carl
number four is baby Judith dead Beth got
off the bus to go get her and the car
seat was unbuckled so it's possible that
she or someone else who was injured
grabbed her and ran because the car seat
was bloody my earlier theory was that it
was Tyreese who kind of looked like he
was carrying something while running off
into the distance episode 9 will
probably answer that question they
probably won't dangle that over us for
too long so we will get an answer soon
number three who is that new villain
episode 9 will be all about the
aftermath of the governor's attack so we
won't meet that new villain for a few
episodes the best theory is that it's
going to be an amalgam of a couple
different characters from the comic
books I already talked about this at
length and it's kind of spoilery so I'll
have a link to that at the end of the
video if you want to learn more about it
question number two will they reach
sanctuary in the comic books this is the
next place they travel to and based on
the timeline at least some of the prison
group will probably make it there I'm
betting that Daryl's group will make it
first just because he was the one to
hear that garbled transmission and in
that message the voice specifically said
sanctuary so I think that's a dead
giveaway and my number one big question
will they reach the Alexandria safe zone
this is actually one of the bigger
questions but the season finale is
called a so it's really possible that
the show will match both sanctuary and
safe zone into one location so let me
know what is your biggest question for
the second half of the season remember
I'm gonna be doing weekly q and A's for
each of the episodes so my next one is
going to be next Monday so I can always
include some of your questions in that
now let's talk about something that's a
little bit more interesting so Scott
Gimple said that AMC the network itself
is really worried about some of the
things the show is going to be doing the
second half of this season the
explanation is is that the show is just
gonna get way more darker as in killing
a major character and perpetrating
hordes as yet unseen in the first three
seasons it's pretty hard to imagine that
there's things that they haven't shown
us but there are a few bit of really
really graphic things that they didn't
include from the comic books the reason
AMC is worried is just that it'll get
too graphic too dark and people will
tune out personally though I think that
people watching Walking Dead understand
that it's supposed to make you feel a
little bit sick
that's like the test of being a real
human if it makes you sick you have a
soul here's a really big question though
is there anything that the walking deck
could do either good or bad with its
characters that would make you want to
stop watching the show now like I
promised details on the giveaway I think
I'm gonna change its just a little bit
originally it was gonna be all about you
know guessing who's gonna die each week
I think I'm just gonna make it way
simpler and just pick a random
subscriber from the comments on my
review videos and just give the $20 gift
card to that person I will still be
doing those Monday bonus videos though
so review videos will post on Sundays
after the episodes Monday will be a QA
and then the other one will be a bonus
video it'll probably be a top 5 kills or
death episode because sometimes the
Walker kills get really epic hopefully
Daryl grabbed a crossbow on his way out
wouldn't it be awesome if he found that
poncho to his crit rating goes through
the roof when he wears it so right now
click here for my top 10 predictions for
the second half of the season and click
here for all my Superbowl trailers there
was actually some really cool ones thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tonight high fives